Kerry lake has not been mentioned on
this show for a while but this is just
too outrageous not to mention Kerry Lake
now has a new story about what happened
in November the new story is God told
her that she would lose her election in
Practical terms but she would still
quote have the victory whatever that
means Carrie Lake did a church prayer
rally it was completely ridiculous and
cartoonish but here's what she had to
say
kind of the whole
is that you're stealing it and yeah
don't you remember how she told us that
right before the election that she was
in her room and the Holy Spirit was
inside of her totally reasonable story
right
the word that this might not go the way
we think it's gonna go oh really the way
I thought it was gonna go because of
what I was seeing on the campaign trail
with the people of Arizona from all
walks of life rather than rural whether
they're a Rancher whether they're a
stay-at-home mom a businessman a student
a youngster we had come together in this
great movement because we want to have
our state going great prosperous
wonderful direction right and so I
figured with this movement unlike we've
ever seen that was led by God
who used me with the skills I had to
help lead it and get everyone together
we were going to have a landslide
victory
which by the way I'll let you know the
secret we did yeah
did you really know
[Music]
um
the victory will still be yours but it's
not going to go the way they think it's
going to go so you're going to lose in
the Earthly sense but you will have won
in some other Cosmic sense and I just
said to him it's all for you whatever
you want whatever you need and I do
believe with every fiber of my being
that we needed to open more eyes and
wait more people up right so listen take
your pick is this a grift or is this
mental illness who's crazier the person
who says this or the person who believes
it and I continue to be shocked by the
amount of time that God has for American
politics Arizona Politics as well as
athletic events and everything it just
it is unbelievable the detail-oriented
nature of this God and so I as of course
everything she says is incoherent I
guess now she's saying we did win in a
landslide just not by the by the votes
but you have the victory
and God told you this a couple weeks
before
at some point
there really needs to be a public
conversation in the United States
about the toxic relationship with
religion that exists among the American
right wing it's not that the right or
the only ones that are religious but
this particularly toxic relationship
where their alleged religious whatever
are uh used in this particular way it's
one of the most toxic things that I've
said before I'm not saying Italy is
perfect in any way but you know in Italy
Italy is a Catholic country and I have
lots of friends from Italy and they all
nominally identify as Catholic they are
all horrified by this form of religion
and its interplay with civil government
in the United States because being
Catholic in a place like Italy for most
people
means something dramatically different
than when someone in the United States
on the American right says I'm a
Christian we're talking about very
different things and this is so toxic
but again
who's crazier Carrie Lake for saying
this stuff or the room full of people
that accepts it you tell me make sure
you're subscribed to our YouTube channel
which you can find at youtube.com slash
the davidpackman show one of our
sponsors is zipx nicotine toothpicks
don't you think it's time you stopped
putting smoke and vape oils in your
lungs zippix toothpicks are a convenient
way to curb the nicotine Cravings zipx
toothpicks are super discreet you can
use them anytime anywhere smoking and
vaping aren't allowed including flights
sporting events in restaurants they're
available in six different flavors with
options of two and three milligrams of
nicotine if you're not a nicotine user
zipix also offers caffeine and b12
infused toothpicks zipx has already
helped tens of thousands of customers
ditch the cigarettes ditch the Vapes
they might be able to help you too if
you're a smoker or a vapor give zipx
toothpicks a try your lungs will thank
you go to zipxtoothpicks.com today save
10 with the code pacman10 at checkout
just remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below